on tenait aussi à vous remercier vous
d'être là depuis mais l'émission et de
nous écrire en grand nombre c'est
toujours très apprécié surtout que cette
fois-ci pour nous suggérer des gens qui
font une grande différence dans leur
communauté parfois dans des petites
municipalités où les épiciers et les
épiciers ont un rôle très important
c'est pour ça qu'on est allé rencontrer
Sylvie en Outaouais
nous sommes à Mansfield et pontet Fract
une petite municipalité du Pontiac au
nord-ouest de Gatineau le long de la
rivière des Outaouais je pense que je
suis venu au monde là-dedans mes parents
ont fait l'achat d'un petit dépanneur en
1978 j'avais
10 ans environ ça a été plusieurs
agrandissements puis c'est en 1996 que
le métro ici 8 jours puis c'était je
pense là plus grand rêve qui a toujours
été le mien aussi c'est dans mon sac
on vient rencontrer Marie-France Lévêque
de noter les spectateurs qui voulaient
mettre en lumière Sylvie le propriétaire
du métro en Outaouais voici un extrait
de son courriel que nous envoyait
bonjour J'habite à mansfire des pontets
dans la NRC de Pontiac en Outaouais un
petit village à 20 minutes de l'Ontario
où tout le monde va magaziner on va
aller les rencontrer puis pourquoi vous
avez voulu nommer c'est lui comme
personne importante dans la communauté
parce qu'il y a toujours présente la
municipalité à Cahors est toujours elle
répond oui à tout ce qu'on lui demande
lorsque la pandémie a eu lieu on est à
20 minutes l'Ontario et il faut prendre
en considération que les frontières sont
fermées madame Bella a fait pied-main
pour faire la livraison à domicile même
si celle-ci était pas équipée de
commandes en ligne ou même dans les
municipalités
c'est sûr que la pandémie a fait plein
de choses
nos gens étaient plus ou moins prises
ici donc on a monté un système de
livraison qui s'était tendu dans les 13
différentes municipalités qu'on a ici un
grand territoire je trouve que ça mérite
reconnaissance comment vous recevez tout
ça ça fait très chaud quand même depuis
le covid-19 j'ai vu que Sylvia a
vraiment eu un impact la communauté et
tout le monde me le disait c'est
vraiment une bonne personne c'est
vraiment une personne qui veut faire un
impact la communauté
votre travail c'est au-delà d'être
propriétaire d'une épicerie on dirait je
pense une petite communauté tout le
monde se connaît on veut céder on veut
nous en donner plus on veut que les gens
se sentent comme dans un gros
supermarché
elle fait les démarches pour avoir ce
qu'on veut je sais que elle fait les
démarches pour avoir des nouveautés mais
considérait qu'on est en région éloignée
on n'a pas tout le temps ce qu'on veut
mais je sais qu'elle fait son possible
des fois on a des petits enjeux mais on
fait du mieux qu'on peut pour avoir tout
ce qu'on peut leur offrir aussi
je pense que les cuivre vont faire juste
dans le milieu que ça passe même le
homard est offert pendant cinq semaines
à Mansfield
il n'y a pas que les clients qui
apprécient Sylvie Bellan
[Musique]
ensuite j'ai été adjointe administrative
et maintenant j'ai raté ça oublie c'est
grâce à Sylvie face à monte à tous les
jours comment bien gérer comment bien
franchir mes obstacles que je rencontre
à tous les jours oubliez pas
d'encourager vos équipes c'est un autre
journée on passe le matin j'aime ça
essayer de faire une petite rencontre
avec mes gérants de service de tous les
départements dans le fond puis
de leur donner un peu le goal l'énergie
puis de transmettre l'énergie là à leurs
employés c'est pas toujours facile la
tape dans le dos serait du bien de
reconnaître ce qu'ils font des
encourager
[Musique]
c'est quoi le plus grand défi de ce
travail le plus grand défi serait je
pense de garder ton équipe motivée en
tout temps on a tout des hauts des bas
nous autres quand ça marche pas et là
pour aider super puis si on a des
problèmes on va on monte en haut puis on
y en parle puis à la scène toujours de
nous aider plus possible pour être un
vaste un bon boss je suis pas seulement
que la patronne je suis je suis un ami
je suis quelqu'un qui peut se confier
puis de je pense le plus grand défi ce
serait de prendre le temps de comprendre
et des écouter mais on y arrive on y
arrive toujours
[Musique]